Um,
but now I will actually talk about the declaration of independence.
obviously at the core of today's lecture we have a piece of paper.
Um,
of course it's an iconic piece of paper to us,
but it's a piece of paper,
just the same.
And part of what we're going to be looking at today in this lecture is that
obviously this declaration was more than just a piece of paper produced by a
bunch of guys in one room that actually declaring independence was an event and
it was an event that reached far beyond the second continental Congress and
actually was hashed out in towns and cities throughout the colonies.
And I'll be talking some about that today.
So as you'll see today,
and it'll be logically following through other things that I've said in the
course,
what we're talking about here is a wrenching progress,
a major decision that was an act of treason and action that the colonists new
would set them on a dangerous path.
Now,
given lots of the stuff I've said so far in this course,
hopefully you're expecting your,
you're understanding why this would be a wrenching process.
Why it would seem radical or as radical as it did.
It represented a break from the mother country that American colonists obviously
had long embraced as their own,
as well as a dangerous act that set a collection of colonies in warfare against
the most powerful nation on earth.
So big step.
So it's an important act,
but we need to be careful in assuming that the piece of paper that explained
it's rationale had some kind of magical,
iconic value at the time that it was created because it didn't.
And as you'll see,
it was not seen as the main focus of the process of declaring independence.
And in a way it was almost seen as a formality to the actual act of declaring
independence.
And it wasn't intended to say something dramatically new.
It's come to mean a lot of things over the centuries,
but at the time it was not supposed to be something radically new as Jefferson
put it.
And you know,
all of these,
all of these founder types,
um,
those who live into old age are asked eternally through their old age to tell
us,
you know,
tell us about right Jefferson got all these.
Tell us about the declaration letters from people.
Adam's got the same kind of letters I'm going to be quoting,
um,
later on from one or two of their explanations of what happened surrounding the
declaration of independence.
But in one of these letters when someone asks Jefferson,
you know,
so how did you decide what was going to be in the declaration?
Where do the ideas come from?
And Jefferson said that the declaration was quote,
neither aiming at originality of principle or sentiment,
nor yet copied from any particular and previous writing.
It was intended to be an expression of the American mind.
Hey,
that was what it was,
not only Jefferson intended it to be,
but what he understood the document was supposed to be doing.
So as we'll see in today's lecture,
the declaration isn't filled with original thoughts beaming out of the brain of
Thomas Jefferson.
Rather,
it reflected American assumptions about government and the rights of the body
politic.
So in essence,
it transcribed a mass of ideas that had been brought into the open and defined
by what the colonists took to be British transgressions against their rights as
colonists and as British subjects.
Now,
as I suggested in last Thursday's lecture,
the Declaration of independence came roughly six months after the publication of
common sense in 1776 but it was by no means the only or even the most important
thing that the congress had to do with that time,
which is sort of not what we would express expect given that it's this iconic
document,
and I'll be talking more about the other things that Congress had to do in
Thursday's lecture.
But for now,
I'll say that by the time the second continental Congress met and at first met
in May of 1775 shots had already been fired at Lexington and Concord,
so it's Thomas Paine put it.
I quoted him last week.
The colonies had been set on fire and the congress now face the monumental task
of organizing some kind of other defensive effort or war effort.
But whatever it was,
they had to organize it.
That was going to be a big problem.
It was gonna be a huge challenge that's happening at the same time that
everything that I'm talking about today's happening.
So even as we're debating independence,
the congress also has to do with a whole range of other issues that really are
immediate and pressing and are about Oregon basically organizing a war.
So not surprisingly,
given the British soldiers had killed some colonists in Massachusetts in April
of 1775 when the second continental Congress came into session in May,
there was already a strong feeling of colonial unity and what at the time they
called rage military,
right?
This sort of fervent support of the colonial cause.
And you can see the mood of the colonists generally in the treatment that they
gave the congressional delegates as they traveled down to Philadelphia for the
meeting.
So as Samuel Adams and John Hancock traveled down from Massachusetts and they
met up with delegates from Connecticut and New York as they went south all along
their way,
local militia units came out to accompany them and seemingly to protect them
from the British.
It's not like actually British,
we're going to jump out from Connecticut and shoot down the delegates of the
continental congress,
but still the,
the impulse was there.
These militia came out to guard the delegates heading down to Congress.
And all along the route people came out to watch these delegates as they passed
by and greeted them with shouts of has ah,
has,
ah,
because Ah,
is um,
the 18th century equivalent of hooray his Ah,
um,
which is very somehow 18th century sounding.
I don't know who ray with a Z in.
It just doesn't sound very modern.
Um,
and I have to,
what pops into my head is a million years ago,
actually I had a Hassan moment,
I had a personal,
is that moment in which I was invited to some big black tie celebration of a
founder who shall go nameless.
And um,
at the founder sort of celebration,
all in like our long dresses and Tuxedos black tie event.
The organizer actually got us all to stand and yell three houses for the
founder.
So there's a group of all these very formal people going.
So even now it feels ridiculous to me.
But even at the time I thought,
yeah,
you just,
you haven't lived as an 18th century historian until you've had the chance to
scream Hassan in honor of a founding fathers.
So I had my has a moment,
um,
there's my Hassan moment,
there's an explanation of hose off.
We have a lot of design going for the delegations if they're heading down to
Philadelphia.
Um,
so in all of that has,
ah,
and you can see that the colonial cause is not an isolated effort being managed
by a few dozen men in a room to all of these people at the time,
just after Lexington and Concord,
the mere existence of the congress,
which was a body formed by all of the colonies together,
was proof of colonial unity.
So it had great significance even just on that most basic level.
And actually although people didn't know it at the time,
the continental congress would end up being the sole government for the colonies
until 1781 when the articles of confederation ended up being ratified.
And obviously I'll talk more about that in electric to come
now in Thursday's lecture on common sense,
I mentioned some of the efforts of the second continental congress to reach
reconciliation reconciliation with Britain.
And as I've already said,
the delegates did not arrive in Philadelphia assuming that they were supposed to
be working for independence.
They were working at reconciliation.
Now,
of course,
as I've just explained,
they were also worrying about organizing armed forces for defensive purposes and
they were pursuing these two sort of con conflicting motives at the same time.
So they're thinking about reconciliation and worrying about defense I suppose in
case that doesn't work,
we really better worry about that.
So we can't take independence for granted.
We also shouldn't take colonial unity for granted because yes,
there's this rage military people are United because of Lexington and Concord.
But if you look up close at the continental congress,
you can see some of the ways in which it really wasn't one United body,
but it really did represent independent bodies,
independent colonies joining together for the moment.
So one example,
there was actually no single method set to determine how many delegates should
attend from each colony.
So basically each colony decided on its own how many people it felt like sending
to the second continental congress.
So Virginia sent seven men and then they seem to have some kind of rotation
systems.
So the guys always seem to be coming and going,
Whoa,
we've got these guys there,
let's take them home.
And bring these new guys there and no one else really knew the system of what
was happening in Virginia,
but they always had people there.
They just changed a lot.
New York ultimately appointed 12 men,
but they didn't come really reliably.
And so ultimately New York decided that you only needed to have three of them
present to vote.
Okay.
So first of all,
obviously attendance is a little quirky,
but beyond that,
every colonies deciding on its own,
how many people that wants to send.
So you can really see how the continental congress is a body encapsulating
delegations from separate and distinct colonies.
And before anything really major could be done,
delegations either needed to confer on their own or more often I suppose confer
with people back home in their colony to determine what it was that their colony
wanted them to do.
And obviously the different ideas and biases and interests in the various
colonies were different enough to make some decisions extremely difficult.
So you've got a pretty distinctive kind of legislative body.
And as I mentioned on Thursday,
one of the notable things that this congress produced was the olive branch
petition,
which was this one final stab at reconciliation.
The olive branch petition was approved on July 5th,
1775 and the hope of ending bloodshed,
the petition walked a delicate line declaring loyalty to the king,
not talking about rights or making demands and asking for the kings assistance
in reaching some kind of reconciliation.
So it's appealing to the loyalty.
There's people saying they're loyal to the king,
they're not raging about rights and demands,
but they are asking for assistance and helping somehow to smooth things over.
Unfortunately,
the petition reached the king at the same time as news of Bunker Hill.
Okay.
One of those unfortunate strikes of fate.
So not surprisingly,
the petition did not have a wonderfully convincing impact.
The crown.
And in August of 1775 the king declared the colonies be in rebellion
and basically he ignored,
as I mentioned also in the last lecture,
he ignored the olive branch petition.
And by doing so basically played into the hands of more radical colonists by
making reconciliation.
See pretty unlikely and really almost demanding some more dramatic action from
the colonies.
So August of 1775 George the third declares the colonies in rebellion.
He also did two other things at roughly that time,
neither one of which helped the situation or certainly helped to smooth it over
at all.
So number one,
two months later,
in October of 1775 he stated in parliament that the American rebellion was
carried on for the purpose of establishing an independent empire.
And this is October,
1775 you're not in 1776 yet.
The king explained that the authors and promoters of this desperate conspiracy
meant only to amuse by vague expressions of attachment to the parents state and
the strongest protestations of loyalty to me whilst they are preparing for a
general revolt.
Okay.
First of all,
it sounds like he actually saw that petition,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
They're claiming were so loyal to you.
And then at the same time,
there's a desperate conspiracy lurking.
So the king is arguing that actually already they're planning revolt and he
says,
you can see this because the colonists are raising troops because they'd seize
the public revenue because they were trying to seize governmental powers.
Not all members of parliament agreed with this.
This sort of conspiracy theory on the part of the king,
those who supported the American cause argued that the American colonies had not
yet declared themselves in revolt.
They had not said that they were rebelling.
They had not said that they wanted independence yet.
And by speaking as he was,
the king could very well push the colonies into more radical action.
And they had yet declared in 1775 but the majority of members of parliament at
the time supported the king statement,
supported his actions.
So first he declares the colonies and rebellion.
Second,
he makes this bold statement in parliament.
And then finally third in December of 1775 he proposed and parliament passed a
prohibitory act and the prohibitory act prohibited commerce with the colonies
period and said that colonial ships,
we're no longer under British protection.
So basically colonial American ships are fair game on the open seas.
Okay.
That's clearly,
there's another bold sort of slap on the part of the crown.
When news of these actions arrived in the colonies in January and February,
1776 many colonists were pushed towards really serious consideration of
independence for the first time.
They're at least considering it aided.
Of course,
as I explained last week by common sense,
the prohibitory act was particularly upsetting to many because it made it lawful
to attack and read American ships as,
as John Hancock put it in a pretty obvious statement.
The making all our vessels lawful prize don't look like a reconciliation.
Like thank you John Hancock and you're right.
John Adams went further stating that the prohibitory act should be called the
act of independency because it makes us independent in spite of our
supplications and in treaties.
Despite that kind of statement,
it is important to remember regardless of how logical,
even at this moment,
independent seems to us,
we still need to go through a process here.
We're still,
it's still not an obvious choice.
And there were lots of questions hovering with the mere thought of independence.
What kind of a future does declaring independence hold?
Many well realized that that kind of a declaration would bring with it a
devastating war with Great Britain,
death and destruction of various kinds and then quite possibly even probably
defeat.
And on top of these pretty logical fears,
even as independence seemed,
at least it's part of debate if not absolutely looming on the horizon.
Most colonists still assumed they're fighting for British rights despite the
fact that clearly their understanding of the British constitution and colonial
rights is differing by this point.
From that,
the understanding of those same things in England,
most colonists still had so deep a connection with the mother country that
independence almost felt like a physical condition.
And John Dickinson,
who is a moderate at this period basically put that into words and said that,
um,
by declaring independence,
the colonies were being torn from the body to which we are United by religion,
liberty laws,
affections,
relations,
language and commerce.
So it's almost a physical ripping away.
So this is the atmosphere in which common sense comes out and buy swaying large
portions of the people towards independence.
Obviously that pamphlet is extremely important.
One of the most important things about it is that because it's suede large
groups of people,
it wasn't just a high falutin political pamphlet written for the elite,
but it really,
as I've mentioned already was for the masses that it enabled the continental
congress to consider independence and ultimately to move towards independence as
representatives of the popular will.
Right?
So common sense is swaying the people and so the continental congress now is
basically acting on the popular will,
some who favored independence actually wanted to distribute common sense at the
congresses expense since it was so useful in arousing public sentiment to move
towards independence.
Now I want to turn at this point to something that often gets left behind or
left out when we talk about declaring independence,
but it's actually really crucial and in a way I think it's really at the center
of the story.
And what I want to talk about is what people generally in the colonies thought
about independence.
Because obviously it's not only guys in the continental congress who are
debating,
discussing and considering independence.
And even there,
there was great recognition that they are acting on the heart on behalf of the
larger populous.
Many colonial delegations felt compelled to have direct orders from the people
of their colony before taking this kind of an enormous step.
And there's a book by Pauline Mayor,
um,
which is titled American Scripture Making the Declaration of independence.
Um,
and it makes this point really well.
It's,
and this,
this sort of larger point that I'm going to make here as partly drawn from her
book.
Um,
and she emphasizes that the continental congress wasn't the sole focal point for
discussion of independence.
And she explains in her book that while she was studying what was going on in
the colonies during the months of April,
May,
June,
and July of 1776,
she actually discovered over 90 other declarations of independence.
All of them written by local communities or towns or conventions representing
individual colonies.
And as she states in her book,
these local declarations of independence get us as close as we can to the voice
of the colonial public on the eve of independence.
And actually just looking at the process of creating these local declarations
reveals a vast amount of information about how the people at large,
we're mobilized,
how seriously many colonies took the idea that the people at large had to
request independence,
that the delegates in the continental congress,
we're representing them.
And just the way I suppose the congress that the colonists felt parliament was
not.
So for example,
in Massachusetts,
the assembly asked individual towns throughout the colony to have meetings to
discuss,
and this is a quote from the document that the assembly sent to all of these
towns.
If the honorable continental congress should decide that for the safety of the
United colonies,
it was necessary to declare them independent of Great Britain,
would they solomnly engage with their lives and fortunes to support the congress
in the measure?
Okay,
so the assembly is sending this and saying pounds,
you need to consider this resolution.
If the Continental Congress decides that it makes sense to declare independence,
will you actually support that with your lives and your fortunes?
Is that something you're in favor of?
Obviously it's being treated like really in a sense,
a personal decision.
A highly significant decision s colonists are asked,
are being asked by the statement to join in groups and discuss independence and
decide what it is they think should happen next and clearly.
That kind of statement also reveals that they're aware of the seriousness and
they're aware.
I mean ultimately this is an act of treason that's being debated here.
Now the Massachusetts Assembly thought that,
you know,
they're asking towns to vote that this might not be necessarily a really lengthy
process since already there's a lot of circulating talk about maybe what should
come next.
But actually it wasn't until July that all of the towns reported themselves in
favor of independence.
The process took that long.
It took months because people actually were seriously debating the issue as a
man from one town observed independence was quote,
the greatest and most important question that ever came before this town.
Now,
of course,
by the time that every town had reported what it thought in Massachusetts to the
continental congress,
the Congress had already decided in favor of independence,
but the people were a part of this decision making process.
And if the first towns from Massachusetts had not supported independence,
the Massachusetts delegates might have had a hard time promoting it in
Philadelphia.
So it mattered in Maryland as well.
There was widespread participation in this decision about whether independence
off to be declared and individual popular declarations supporting independence
there were possibly even more important than in Massachusetts because the
Maryland congressional delegation was undecided in what it thought about
independence.
And it wasn't until the Maryland government received these declarations of
independence from towns in Maryland that they decided to instruct the delegates
in the Congress to support independence.
Some colonies,
like at this point,
I should just wait for the response.
Which colony might have a quirky response,
right?
Rhode Island,
somewhere out there in and like the filming land,
you know,
they're filming this,
this,
there's gonna be a lot of Rhode Island people were going to be really mad at me
for saying negative things about Rhode Island and yet here we have Rhode Island.
Again,
Rhode Island did not have such widespread participation.
There was a logic to what went on in Rhode Island.
Um,
apparently in Rhode Island the legislature did consider asking towns what they
thought about independence,
but they did a little investigation first and they discovered that it was
possible that a few towns in Rhode Island might vote against independence.
Okay.
Rhode Island wisely thought,
if we ask people what they think and they say we don't want independence,
this could be a bad thing.
And so I decided that wasn't necessarily the best plan.
Certainly it wouldn't help the common cause.
Now when I discuss colonial legislatures at this point point,
it's important to realize that most of the royal colonial governments had pretty
much collapsed by this point.
The continental congress in May of 1776 thus instructed the colonies to form new
governments.
And so roughly throughout this period,
some of the colonies had already started doing this before may some of the
waited until May,
but throughout this period in a lot of the colonies there was some kind of a
convention debating what basically the new government and really in a way the
new constitution of these colonies should be in the absence of having a royal
presence.
So they're like little Leni colonial constitutional conventions.
And it was these conventions often that we're receiving these local declarations
of independence and to some people in the colonies,
it was actually this resolution asking the colonies to create their own
governments that constituted the real declaration of independence.
And you can even hear echoes of the later official declaration in the resolution
itself asking the colonies to make their own governments.
It has a preamble,
a very radical preamble that certainly we're radical than anything that the
congress had said thus far.
Whereas his Britannic Majesty in conjunction with the Lords and comments of
Great Britain has by a late act of parliament,
excluded the inhabitants of these United colonies from the protection of the
crown and whereas no answer,
whatever to the humble petitions of the colonies for redress of grievances and
reconciliation with Great Britain has been or is likely to be given.
But the whole force of that kingdom aided by foreign mercenaries is to be
exerted for the destruction of the good people of these colonies.
It is necessary that the exercise of every kind of authority under the said
crown should be totally suppressed and all the powers of government exerted
under the authority of the people of the colonies for the preservation of
internal peace,
virtue,
and good order as well as for the defense of their lives,
liberties and properties.
So it's a radical statement to Adams,
John Adams as well as many others.
This pretty much constituted a declaration of independence even though it didn't
declare independence officially.
And it's significant that in that preference,
in that preface,
Congress isn't attacking the king's ministers.
They're not attacking parliament.
They're attacking the king himself,
which is almost as good as a formal declaration of revolt.
Meanwhile,
in the colonies,
the individual towns are debating what they want to do about independence.
They are expressing their opinions and written statements that as Pauline mayor
points out,
we're remarkably alike in tone and content.
A lot of them listed the same grievances and had the same kind of sense of
betrayal at how the king had betrayed them.
Most of them mentioned the contempt with which the king had received their
attempts at reconciliation.
They mentioned recent violence and destruction of American property by British
troops.
They,
of course mentioned the prohibitory act,
which declared the con the colonists out of British protection.
They mentioned German mercenaries hired by George the third to fight the
colonists,
and most of them had a sort of a personal tone that they adopted towards the
king blaming him personally for the present state of affairs and expressing
great sadness at their realization that their,
their monarch basically had fallen to this level and allowed this to happen.
Some petitions went even further suggesting the type of government that they'd
prefer to be there in place of the monarchy.
And in one way or another,
some of these declarations specified they wanted to establish a republican
government in the colonies.
They wanted governments grounded on popular will,
an actual representation.
So what we're seeing here is average people in towns throughout the colonies
immersed in the current state of affairs,
committing themselves personally to a course of action,
expressing their ideas about what government should be and personally taking
part in the political process in a radical kind of a way.
So obviously we're not talking about a couple of dozen men in a room in
Philadelphia.
Now,
news of these declarations written in May,
June,
and even as late as July helped push the continental congress towards
independence.
So let's move back to Congress.
On June 7th,
1776 Virginia took a major step forward by making a resolution that it sent to
it's delegates and Philadelphia via Richard Henry Lee,
who was one of the delegates.
And the resolution from Virginia said that the delegates should promote
independence because the colonies are and of right ought to be free and
independent states.
Bang.
So there you have it.
But the response,
okay,
there it is.
We should be independent.
The resolution that's going to push them to debate independence,
the response to that resolution is a reminder that there were a lot of other
things that were more pressing at the time.
So Richard Henry Lee presents this to Congress and Congress says,
we got to put it off till tomorrow because we actually have more important
things that we need to debate today first.
So hold on about independence tomorrow.
Thank you Richard.
And really onto these other matters.
So the next day,
June 8th debate on independence got underway.
And those who are less enthusiastic about independence,
men like John Dickinson who is moderate in his politics or James Wilson also of
Pennsylvania.
Um,
Edward Rutledge of South Carolina.
They said that they were friends to the idea,
but at the time wasn't yet right.
Some colonial delegations weren't yet ready to declare independence.
They didn't have permission to declare it from their home governments and
forcing the issue might force these colonies to succeed from what was already a
relatively weak colonial union or so they argued.
So and disunion if that were to happen,
if they were to push independence and a colony should pull out,
this union would be disastrous to their cause.
Not only because it would hurt the cause,
but it would certainly not encourage foreign nations to potentially help these
little colonies in fighting against Great Britain.
So this is what Rutledge,
Edward Rutledge of South Carolina wrote on June 10th the Congress that till
seven o'clock this evening and consequence of emotion of Richard Henry Lee's
rendering ourselves free and independent states,
the sensible part of the house oppose the motion.
They saw no wisdom in a declaration of independence nor any other purpose to be
enforced by it.
But placing ourselves in the power of those with whom we mean to treat,
giving our enemy notice of our intentions before we had taken any steps to
execute them and thereby enabling them to counter act us in our intentions and
rendering ourselves ridiculous in the eyes of foreign powers by attempting to
bring them into a union with us before we had United with each other.
There's a lot of strong arguments Rutledge just presenting,
but of course on the other side of the spectrum,
those who supported independence argued that without a formal declaration of
independence,
no nation would be willing to aid the colonies.
The colonies are basically independent already.
The matter needs to be discussed.
It needs to be pushed forward,
lack of agreement and the importance of the decision led Congress to postpone
the decision until the first week of July so that individual colonies could
decide on a course of action and in the meantime so no time would be lost.
They appointed a committee to compose a written statement formally declaring
colonial independence.
And the committee included John Adams,
Thomas Jefferson,
Benjamin Franklin,
greatest hits,
Roger Sherman of Connecticut,
and Robert Are Livingston,
one of the many living students of New York.
And ultimately the committee appointed Jefferson to draft the document.
And he worked during the last two weeks of June in 1776.
Now,
as I mentioned at the start of the lecture in later years when Adams and
Jefferson were retired presidential types,
um,
lots of people wrote to them asking,
you know,
so tell us what really happened with the declaration of independence.
What was it like?
Why didn't you do x?
Did you really do x?
What was he,
you know,
sort of all the things that you would want to ask if you could ask these people,
like what really happened?
And both men offered accounts of the writing of the declaration and their
accounts do not necessarily agree.
And they're also pretty a character for each one of these men,
particularly John Adams account of what happened with the decision about who's
going to write the declaration of independence.
And,
and actually in 1822 Adams wrote a pretty lengthy explanation of how Jefferson
was chosen to write the declaration.
I just want to offer you a little piece of it because it's actually a pretty
amazing little recreation.
So Adams writes in his letter,
you inquire why so young man is Mr. Jefferson was placed at the head of the
committee for preparing a declaration of independence.
Okay,
so there's the what the person wrote.
So a lot of them,
it's like,
why did you pick that young new guy to write this document?
Adam says,
I answer.
Mr. Jefferson came into congress in June,
1775 and brought with him a reputation for literature,
science and a happy talent of composition.
Writings of his were handed about remarkable for the peculiar Felicity of
expression though a silent member in Congress.
He was so prompt,
frank,
explicit and decisive upon committees and in conversation,
not even Samuel Adams was more so,
but he soon seized upon my heart.
And upon this occasion I gave him my vote and did all in my power to procure the
votes of others.
Okay.
So in the end,
the committee's voting,
who should write it and Adams and Jefferson get the most votes to write the
declaration.
So they're made according to Adam's like a little subcommittee of Adams and
Jefferson.
And now the subcommittee,
supposedly he's going to draft the declaration.
So Adam's continues.
The sub committee met Jeffers and proposed to me to make the draft.
I said,
I will not and and what I'm going to be reading from here now,
it's my favorite part of this story.
He wrote a little script like what Jefferson says.
And when he responds,
he's no longer even like himself and the letter,
he's just recording like he said.
And then I said,
and then he said,
and then I said,
so Jefferson says,
Adams,
you should write it.
And Adam says,
I will not.
You should do it.
Jefferson insists.
Oh no,
says Adams.
Why will you not as Jefferson?
You ought to do it.
This is like,
he's like writing a film.
He's already imagining like the movie of my life.
If movies existed,
I would be imagining the movie of my life.
You ought to do it says Jefferson.
I will not.
Why reason enough?
What can be your reasons?
Okay.
This is Adam's response reason.
First,
you are a Virginian and Virginia not to appear at the head of this business.
Reason second,
I am obnoxious,
suspected and unpopular.
Oh,
John Adams.
I am of noxious,
suspected it unpopular.
Don't make me write the document.
You are very much otherwise reason.
Third,
you can write 10 times better than I can.
Well Adam has respond if you are decided,
I will do it as well as I can.
Okay.
That's part of a really lengthy,
great letter by Adams.
Jefferson's account is much less humorous and actually briefer and he writes in
1823 to James Madison and he says no such thing as a sub committee with
proposed.
It's like basic disagreement but they unanimously pressed on myself alone to
undertake the draft.
Okay.
Little disagreement between the two guys,
which they never really agreed upon and he then goes on to discuss in this
letter whether the ideas and the declaration were new or not and he says,
no,
no American mind,
blah,
blah.
Okay.
Regardless of the precise details as to whether there was or wasn't a
subcommittee.
Jefferson did draft the declaration,
he submitted it to the others for comment.
Um,
they commented on it,
they sort of discussed it amongst themselves.
You'll get some chance in section to actually talk about some of the real
specifics of the document,
the declaration of independence for the moment.
I'll just mention briefly,
um,
what were some of Jefferson sources?
Right.
He's sitting in Philadelphia.
He has basically two weeks talk about a paper deadline to write the declaration
of independence.
Um,
what is he going to use?
He's pretty pressed for time.
So logically he turned to whatever he could for fodder.
And two notable sources were both Virginia documents.
Logically enough,
he drafted a constitution for Virginia since the colonies in the middle of doing
that and along with everything else.
And that ended up being a source for him of some of the grievances,
that long list of grievances in the declaration.
He pulled some of them from that.
And then the Virginia Declaration of Rights,
which was also part of this constitution making process helped contribute to the
preamble of the declaration.
Now of course Jefferson was careful not just to focus on Virginia words,
Virginia charges,
Virginia things because obviously the document is supposed to represent all of
the colonies.
So for example,
when you read the declaration,
you could see some of the things he siding happened in Massachusetts and some of
them actually happened in other colonies as well.
It needs to be something that is coming from some United expression of the
colonial will,
one of the passage that ultimately did not end up displaying colonial unity,
not surprisingly concerned slavery.
So in Jefferson's draft,
he actually has a passage that charges the king that the king quote had waged
cruel war against human nature itself,
violating its most sacred rights of life and liberty in the persons of a distant
people who never offended him,
captivating and carrying them into slavery in another hemisphere or to encour
miserable death and their transportation either.
Okay,
so that's a notable attempt to blame the king for slavery.
But the passage ultimately gets stricken out by the congress in part for obvious
reasons,
right?
The South is not going to support this,
but also ultimately Jefferson's declaration as far as slavery is concerned,
had some tortured logic in it because at first the tax the king for creating
slavery for transporting slaves to America and then attacks him for offering
them freedom.
If they fight for the British,
you inflicted slavery upon us and you're threatening to free the slaves.
Okay.
Continental Congress said,
okay,
not only is the south not really able to grasp this at this particular woman,
but this doesn't entirely match up Jefferson.
So in a sense,
his ambiguity and ambivalence reflected general ambiguity and ambivalence.
But in the end,
the total effect of all of these charges was to suggest that the king,
that sort of deep kinged himself,
he had displaced himself,
that he and not the colonies had brought events to where they now stood.
Now,
you know,
I think generally we,
and also often scholars tend to really focus on the preamble of the declaration,
but in fact at the time it was the specific charges against the king that were
considered to be the real meat of the document.
The preamble was actually just supposed to be a preamble to the real charges
against the king,
which were the radical part of the document at the time.
And since this document was intended possibly to be a declaration for foreign
audiences as well as domestic audiences,
it was important that that preamble be a statement,
a broad sweeping statement of epic proportions to inspire people to support the
cause,
the committee's draft.
Ultimately,
it was presented to Congress on June 28th and then debating and editing began on
July 1st.
Um,
some of the changes had to do with specific word choices.
So for example,
was the king really guilty of quote unremitting injuries?
Congress preferred repeated injuries.
Yeah.
That was the level of editing taking place in the declaration.
Um,
so they thought,
well repeated as a little less extreme than unremitting.
That word gets changed.
Not all of the changes were intended to tame the document.
Sometimes Congress made some of Jefferson's charges more extreme as when they
added to Jefferson statement about foreign mercenaries.
Words that described it,
the act of sending them to the colonies as quote scarcely paralleled in the most
barbarous ages.
And then as I mentioned before,
they struck the entire passage on slavery for this.
For many southern delegates,
pretty much it was a deal breaker.
And as happens so often in this period will certainly come up with it.
Again,
I think towards the end of this course,
the issue of slavery comes up.
It can't be dealt with.
People don't know how to deal with it,
particularly the southerners,
and it keeps getting shunted to the side.
And so in a sense that's what happens here.
Um,
I'm going to stop at this point.
and I will start with a story that should be here,
but I can't tell it here and I want to do it justice about Jefferson's response
to the editing of his precious draft.
He was not a happy camper at the editing of the declaration of independence.
And then I will move on,
uh,
to really discussing organizing a war.